if the ethiopian army has achieved a
glorious victory
in the state of tigre there was little
sign of it on state television
instead we saw images of troops
operating behind the front line
one day after their prime minister abi
ahmed declared the mission
an unqualified success a number of
small-scale celebrations
were captured on social media here
pro-government militiamen
wave their weapons in western tigray
and a government spokesman said the
capital michele
had been taken with a minimum of fuss
residents of the macaulay city have been
very very cooperative
since the defense forces have taken over
a critical
facilities government facilities have
been taken over including
the regional administration's office the
airport
hospitals as well so some of these
critical infrastructures are under the
federal command
but the party that ran this rebellious
region
the tplf says the conflict's only begun
we want lovers and haters to know
this conflict has caused a humanitarian
crisis
tens of thousands have been displaced
with many
seeking sanctuary in neighboring sudan
but it could turn into a catastrophe the
red cross says
hospitals in mckele are running short of
medical supplies
and the ethiopian government is
preventing the un
from assisting those in desperate need
the great difficulty and the great
concern is that we still have no access
to people in need so one strong appeal
that
we've put out for the federal
authorities in ethiopia is to
grant again that access we've heard talk
about
humanitarian corridors access that's all
good but we need to see concrete
action there and has action been taken
very limited so far
the un says 100 000 tigrayans may flee
to sudan
but this country is barely able to care
for them
[Applause]
it already hosts one million refugees
from right across
africa we spoke to a number of them on
the streets of the capital khartoum
some said they've been stranded here for
years
we are tired we don't get any supports
health care we don't have health care
our children they're in the road
no education no protection
so we are tired that's why we decide to
camping here for the robot solution
individuals and families sleep outside
the office of the un's refugee agency
a sort of protest come appeal for
permanent relocation
twenty-two-year-old munageta has spent
her whole life
as a refugee you cannot go to school
especially for me
and for us we can't go to school we've
got to teach ourselves
and our parents have to teach us also
so it's really difficult you can't i
can't have friends i never had any
friends all my
i can't have it's only my parents and my
sisters are my friends
so no friends no social life
it may be hard but sudan is relatively
secure
and there are tens of thousands of
ethiopians who have nowhere else to go
john sparks sky news cartoon